just as Pennywise from stephen king's it
has many faces the terrifying monster
clown is too big an idea for just one
franchise creepy clowns have appeared in
a wide variety of movies over the years
and they're just as terrifying now as
they ever were here are some movies
featuring deadly clowns you might not
have met and who may haunt your
nightmares once you do series clown
brought to you by future spider-man
homecoming director John watts clown was
shot in 2012 but it took until 2016 to
find distribution in the US it's a
genuinely disturbing film featuring one
of the most terrifying ly inhuman clowns
ever to appear on screen
Kent's just a regular guy but when his
son's birthday party is almost ruined
after the clown cancels Kent puts on an
old suit and plays the role himself
unfortunately the suit is cursed and he
starts transforming into a demonic clown
with an insatiable need to eat the flesh
of children so they have fun with that
stitches stitches wasn't a very good
clown to begin with but his career and
his life ended when some kids tied his
shoelaces together and he fell onto an
upturned knife and died six years later
those kids are teenagers having a party
in the same house and stitches rises
again to take his revenge complete with
go-go-gadget clown murder Arms All
Hallows Eve in the three-part anthology
All Hallows Eve a babysitter working on
Halloween finds a videotape of a
murdering clown in a kid's
trick-or-treat bag
soon the clown on the tape begins to
appear in the real world All Hallows Eve
director Damien Lyon created art the
clown years before the movies 2013
release for his short films Terra Fire
and the ninth circle both of which were
incorporated into All Hallows Eve the
killer clown is set to return in Leone's
next film a feature-length version of
Terra Fire amusement the 2008 film is
split into sections focusing on three
girls attempting to escape from a maniac
in clown makeup before he became the
masked clown the movie's main character
was a psychologically unbalanced child
who was picked on by those same three
girls now that they're all grown he's
hunting them down and taking revenge
clown house it's basically the perfect
setup for a low-budget 1989 horror movie
three escaped mental patients kill some
clouds at the circus and steal their
costumes
then follow three teenage brothers home
to their big isolated house creepy music
and murder ensue
unfortunately the real-life
circumstances of clown houses production
turned out to be far more disturbing
than its story director victor salva was
convicted of molesting the actor who
played the youngest brother and the
story resurfaced when Salva after a
brief prison stay was hired by Disney to
direct powder in 1995 anyone who knows
the story is understandably going to
find clown house hard to watch
blood harvest Merville the marvelous is
unique among the clowns on this list
he's not necessarily the killer and
blood harvest he's just hanging around
being creepy in the town where the
killings are happening played by Tiny
Tim the falsetto singing ukulele player
Merv Oh is the older brother of the
ex-boyfriend of Jill the film's
protagonist - some flowers Dale when
everyone who Jill cares about starts
dying Merv Oh is one of the possible
suspects obviously when people are
mysteriously dropping dead that guy in
town who likes to wear clown makeup is
going to look pretty suspicious blood
harvest turned out to be little more
than a footnote in Tiny Tim's unusual
career but it's certainly weird enough
to be worth a look for enthusiasts of
the clown horror sub-genre vulgar have
you ever wanted to watch Jay and Silent
Bob fight a killer clown while vulgar is
your chance Kevin Smith produced and
acted in this ultra low-budget 2004
comedy about a murderous clown named
vulgar who wants revenge on the men who
assaulted him vulgar was directed by
Brian Johnson and stars Brian O'Halloran
best known as Dante from clerks in the
title role killer clowns from outer
space after it's 1988 release killer
clowns from outer space became a minor
cult classic but it's not as widely
remembered or beloved as it once was
it tells the story of clown like aliens
who arrived on earth and flying saucers
that look like circus tents and begin
massacring and eating all the humans
they find often in ridiculous ways that
resemble circus performances
[Music]
killer clouds from outer space was the
only film written and directed by the
Chiodo brothers special effects artists
who also created the titular monsters
for the critters movies Gacy John Wayne
Gacy might be the scariest killer clown
of all for the simple reason that he
actually existed a family man and
respected community member Gacy turned
out to have the bodies of more than 30
people buried underneath his house the
biopic Gacy came out in 2003 and while
it's not a widely remembered or popular
film it's a must-see if you're
interested in true crime or killer
Klowns how we aren't strangers finally
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]